és ugyanúz érvényes magára a promptolási
technikákra ahogy mondtuk tehát maga az
hogy hogyan lépünk interakcióba a chat
gpt-vel hogy a a az átlag felhasználó
aki nem tudja ezt meg tudja kérni a chat
gpt-t hogy taníts meg engem hogy hogyan
használjalak téged készíts egy
tananyagot hogy hogyan tanuljak meg jól
veled interakcióba lépni és segíts nekem
kitalálni azt hogy hol tudom használni
az én életemben az adott kontextusomba
tegyük fel én egy könyvelő vagyok
romániában erdélyi magyar környezetben
segíts nekem megtalálni azt azokat a
módszereket hogy a a hatékonyságom
növekedjen a következő időszakban
azáltal hogy téged használak és erről
készíts egy tananyagot nekem amit két
perces rövid tartalmakban el tudok
olvasni